this morning G-Man the first major
biography of J Edgar Hoover in three
decades and a new look at the most
important non-elected official of the
20th century Jay Edgar Hoover served as
FBI director for almost 50 years shaping
this country in unprecedented ways the
author of this towering book is Beverly
Gage who we met where she works as a
professor at Yale University
each of the special agents of the
Federal Bureau of Investigation must be
ready and capable to meet any challenge
Jay Edgar Hoover served eight presidents
four Democrats and four Republicans the
kind of bipartisan survival that seems
impossible today as Beverly Gage writes
about in G-Man J Edgar Hoover and the
making of the American Century one of
the things that really fascinated me
about Hoover and that I think people
don't think about very much now is that
he did that not just by strong arming
people and threatening them but because
he was actually really popular for most
of his career and had very widespread
support especially in Washington
Hoover's initial vision for the FBI was
a white collar organization that
primarily pushed paper and focused on
forensics a bullet fired into cotton
Bears Telltale Gun Barrel markings the
fingerprints of the weapon which Walter
Cronkite helped to show us in this 1958
CBS special the story of the FBI a speck
of paint taken from a bumper reveals the
make year and model of a car involved in
a crime but violence eventually LED FBI
agents to respond in kind
from Mafia battles to rooting out
enemies at home during World War II to
navigating the Civil Rights Movement J
Edgar Hoover had his hand in all of it
they they seek to weaken law enforcement
in every conceivable manner born January
1st 1890 John Edgar Hoover lived in
Washington D.C his entire life
his dad battled lifelong depression
Hoover's mother was his Rock Hoover
lived with his mom until he was 43 years
old and so here he is he's this big
National celebrity by the 1930s he's
running you know domestic intelligence
and crime fighting for the federal
government and he's actually just living
in his childhood home sleeping in his
childhood bedroom coming home to his mom
every night Hoover never got married
for four decades he traveled and
entertained with the number two man at
the FBI Clyde Tolson it's really clear
that the primary relationship of his
life was with Clyde Tolson it was a
pretty open social relationship so it
wasn't as if they were keeping that a
secret they went to nightclubs and
racetracks together they traveled
together if you were going to invite
Edgar to dinner you also invited Clyde
they signed their holiday cards you know
often Edgar and Clyde to their close
friends as much as anything else Hoover
is known for his career-long hatred of
Communism Communists have been still are
and always will be a menace to freedom
to democratic ideals for the worship of
God and to America's way of life it
defined his his worldview his life view
right forever yeah that's actually what
fascinated me and what made me want to
write a biography about him in part is
that I saw these ideas in formation
today Hoover is remembered as a man who
yes checked communism
but also hindered other progress
including the infamous cointel Pro
operations in which the FBI spied on
American political groups by
burglarizing wiretapping and collecting
damaging information on critics and
leaders like Dr Martin Luther King Jr
Gage says Hoover almost always acted
with a knowledge and permission of the
presidents he served you say that after
more than a decade of study you did not
emerge and admirer of J Edgar Hoover why
well I think Hoover was a big Force for
kind of limiting Democratic possibility
in the 20th century you know he
understood himself actually to be the
person policing the limits of American
democracy and for him that sometimes
meant going after violent organizations
like the Ku Klux Klan but often it meant
going after left-wing organizations and
people he simply didn't agree with
Hoover died in office at the age of 77
after 48 years in charge
a half century leader the FBI has never
had another leader who's been able to
cajole Democrats and befriend
Republicans the way Hoover did
for better
and worse
why couldn't he walk away I think he
thought the FBI couldn't survive without
him and so you know his his life and the
institution he created were just so
fused that that he couldn't let go
post Hoover the new rule became your FBI
director for 10 years right and that's
it and what's really interesting is you
look at the polls and it's pretty
obvious you just look in general
after Hoover left Republicans tended to
love the FBI and Democrats distrusted it
didn't like it very much today it's the
exact opposite
so a lot has changed since he left again
nobody's had that same power he has as
we said for better and worse you're
really interesting in your piece Jeff
there were several things that kept
asking you more questions about in just
learning about him that I didn't know
forget the time in office even just
about him as a person check out the book
G-Man I bet she did a wonderful job with
it great stuff